palmarès du festival de cannes ce
triomphe du cinéma américain giscard à
khartoum vers des conversations
europe/afrique pays arabes
bernard hinault premier au banc tout est
en tête du dauphiné libéré
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
le 3e festival international du cinéma
de cannes est terminé celui d'un grand
millésime le juré a proclamé le palmarès
cet après-midi les grands triomphateurs
sont des américains qui remporte la
palme d'or ex-aequo avec les allemands
le prix de la mise en scène le prix de
la meilleure interprétation masculine
le prix de la meilleure interprétation
féminine voyons d'abord avec nos envoyés
spéciaux la palme d'or ex-aequo attribué
à apocalypse now de l'américain copla et
aux tambours de l'allemand chn
un palmarès sans grande surprise pour ce
32ème festival les ce sujet d'étonnement
pour une partie de la presse ont été le
prix d'interprétation attribué à jacques
lemon pour shine marseille rome et le
prix spécial du jury attribué au film
soviétique cyber yade mais dans
l'ensemble le festival a tenu ses
promesses
deux grands noms deux grandes films sont
couronnés par la pâle la palme d'or est
attribué ex-aequo à le tambour de volker
schlöndorff
voilà
non
volker schlöndorff
tout le monde s'attendait à ce que vous
ayez le prix vous venez de la voir et
apparemment être très très calme
je montre pas beaucoup mais les émotions
sauf dans les films
mais je trouve que c'est formidable
formidable pour le film pour le cinéma
européen parce que c'est un film à très
gros budget mais en langue allemande
sans vedette c'était une sorte de
déclaration d'indépendance de l'europe à
l'égard des puissances mondiales du
cinéma
le prix spécial du jury disait jean
rigaud est allé à un metteur en scène
soviétique kontchalovski pour son film
syberia récompense de meilleur
interprète masculin jack lemmon pour son
rôle du film le syndrome chinois
meilleure interprète féminine
sally field pour sa création dans norma
rae mais d'abord syberia de contrôle
dans ce prix spécial du jury dans mon
cas ma kai avenant mais pour le cinéma
soviétique à mon avis c'est à mon avis
c'est très important parce que il y a un
sur deux clichés du cinéma soviétique
doit être ou bien sûr de propagande ou
bien c'est un long c'est ennuyeux et
c'est pas du tout se touchent pas et moi
je voudrais je voudrais toute ma vie
consacrée pour des transactions de
clichés qui élimine été hissé sur
briscoe base aux intérêts allant d'un
chantier sur sa vraie lady catherine
mayenne
ça
ils vont toujours celui qui touche
l'espagne
bien sûr
jack lemmon c'est un rôle inhabituel
pour vous j'ai été très gâtée dans ma
carrière j'ai fait à la fois des
comédies et des rôles dramatiques mais
c'est le film dans lequel je me suis le
plus impliqué
et
ja
m
c'était
je peux faire
énorme arrêt salif sy bassinois mauvaise
c'est vraiment la femme américaine est
je me suis attaché
la mettre en évidence les vrais
problèmes de la vie de norma rae ses
enfants son existence qui est salie fils
de martin ritt sally field est vraiment
comme norma rae c'est une lutteuse c'est
une tigresse et c'est une actrice de
première classe
trois de mes rares en ce moment même le
gala de clôture parachève la fête du
cinéma avec la projection d'un film
français
à nous deux de claude lelouch il faut
souhaiter que la qualité des films du
festival contribue à faire grossir les
rangs des spectateurs dans les salles et
stimule tous les créateurs bien parlons
d'énergie on attendait beaucoup de la
centrale solaire française thémis en
construction à targassonne dans les
pyrénées-orientales
son but produire de l'électricité en
utilisant des rayons du soleil
or la centrale est actuellement arrêté
et l'on peut se demander si les travaux
ne seront pas définitivement abandonné
la raison serait simple aux dires du
commissariat à l'énergie solaire
coordinateur de travaux le coup de
thémis serait trop élevé
les constructeurs c'est à dire le centre
national de la recherche scientifique et
électricité de france ont proposé un
projet - couteau moins coûteux pardon
mais georges leclercq situées ailleurs
oui alors justement temis est un projet
extrêmement ambitieux de la france
puisqu'il représente 45 % de la
recherche total solaire de notre pays il
ya 350 miroir qui suivent le soleil dans
sa course renvoient la lumière vers le
haut d'une tour dans une chaudière celle
ci produit de la vapeur que j'ai tourné
à turbine et donc
de l'électricité produite est bien
thémis aujourd'hui est arrêté pour une
histoire d'argent
alors qu'est ce qui peut se passer
maintenant et bien à un mois de la
célébration de notre jour du soleil sur
antenne 2 vous savez que depuis lundi
j'explique tous les jours 18h40 à c'est
la vie les points particuliers
d'utilisation d'énergie solaire et bien
qu'est ce qui va se passer d'abord
tennis peut repartir si on trouve de
l'argent
après tout quand le surrégénérateurs de
créer smallville double son coût initial
on trouve bien d'argent bon alors mais
ce qu'on veut vraiment et miss repartent
l'a pas forcément parmi les
constructeurs le cnrs doit assister
thaler développe d'autres projets plus
petit moins coûteux mieux exportable
c'est périclès setec les industriels
proposent un autre projet inti le dieu
un cas et l'edf propose son terrain de
saint chamas au nord de marseille enfin
il ya d'autres partisans d'énergie
solaire qui pense que l'idée même de
faire des centrales solaires doit être
abandonnée le soleil reçu partout sur
chaque toit sur chaque arbre sur chaque
capteur solaire
alors pourquoi le concentré de cette
façon énorme et risque un échec
technique
faisons de la place plutôt aux maisons
solaires aux pompes solaires au
chauffe-eau solaire c'est peut-être là
la leçon à tirer de thémis de son échec
de lyon une dépêche une plaque
métallique déposé jeudi dans la boîte à
lettres du journal le progrès ayant été
qualifié par les services de pompiers de
fortement radioactive
la cellule révolutionnaire un tennis
l'ère écologique crâne serra haineux a
revendiqué auprès de l'afp et de lyon le
dépôt de cette plaque qui avait été volé
dans une école d'ingénieurs de lyon
c'est donc un fait divers
giscard d'estaing est rentré à paris de
son voyage en afrique où après des
travaux de kigali
il a fait hier une visite officielle au
soudan c'est la première fois que le
président en exercice de la communauté
européenne monsieur giscard d'estaing
rencontrer le président en exercice de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine en
l'occurrence le président lee mais
giscard d'estaing a demandé au président
ni mairie de soumettre aux instances
africaines
le projet de conférence euro
arabo-africaine dit le trial hoc
le soudan est un pays charnière entre
l'afrique et le monde arabe
et en ce moment et jusqu'au mois de
juillet prochain gerald gaffard el hibri
le chef de l'état soudanais et président
de l'organisation de l'unité africaine
comme la france et présidente de la
communauté européenne communauté
économique européenne n'oublions pas qui
est le principal fournisseur du soudan
comme elle est son principal client
pour toutes ces raisons l'escale de
khartoum était pour valéry giscard
d'estaing une escale utile est obligée
après deux entretiens en tête à tête qui
ont porté bien sûr sur les relations
bilatérales et sur les problèmes
régionaux
le président de la république a été
l'invité d'honneur d'un dîner de 500
couverts à l'issue duquel il s'est
adressé à travers ses hôtes à toutes les
facs lavoie s'est ouverte à des
groupements d'état d'un autre titre ils
ne trouvent pas leur raison d'être dans
la crainte d'une menace extérieure mais
dans la constatation d'affinité
naturelle
il ne se fonde pas sur un principe de
hiérarchie mais sur un principe
d'égalité
il ne vise pas à s'opposer mais à
construire
ils ne servent pas à diviser mais à unir
c'est à cette catégorie qu'appartiennent
la communauté économique européenne
l'organisation de l'unité africaine la
ligue arabe
ce ne sont pas des blocs mais des
familles de nation leur formation ne
résulte pas de la simple conjonction des
intérêts elle s'enracine dans les
solidarités profonde de la géographie de
l'histoire et de la culture
samedi le chef de l'état fait ces cinq
années de présidence à la rabatelière en
vendée dimanche une président des
cérémonies jeanne d'arc à rouen
et je vous rappelle qu'un unique sur ma
cantine de midi présenté par patrick
lecocq sera diffusée demain vendredi en
direct d'ordre parmi les sujets de
préoccupation pour les pays africains
celui de leur intégrité territoriale est
sans doute le plus important
mais ces nations jeunes avec moyens
faibles ne disposent généralement pas de
forces militaires suffisante pour
intervenir avec toute l'efficacité que
souhaiterait leur gouvernement les
grandes puissances ont donc tout un
corps d'intervention prêt
à voler au secours des pays amis la
france n'avait pas exception à la règle
un reportage de patrick lecocq nous
mangerons vient d'être déclenchée nous
devons nous mettre en place dans le pays
concerné avec escale technique à dakar
vale ont décollé de toul nous
rejoindrons selon les procédures en
vigueur le c-130 ray lahood
le liban pour le rhénus kolwezi pour
défendre l'intégrité du territoire
zaïrois et empêcher le massacre de la
population tant européennes
qu'américaines le tchad la mauritanie à
plusieurs reprises ces dernières années
l'armée française est intervenue sur un
théâtre d'opérations extérieures
peut-elle mission présente des
caractéristiques constante des leçons
urgente elles ont un caractère politico
militaire certains et elles ont un
caractère limité
quelques heures seulement après l'ordre
donné par le gouvernement français les
avions essentiellement des jaguars
peuvent quitter la piste ils se poseront
cinq ou six heures plus tard entre temps
à deux ou trois reprises
ils auront rendez vous avec un réservoir
volant fait qu'un kc 135 de
ravitaillement jacques hublin d'exigence
que possède à helmand l'armée de l'air
mais l'essentiel pour une intervention
extérieure ce sont les hommes capables
en quelques heures de quitter leurs
garnisons du midi ou de l'ouest de la
france pour se retrouver dans la savane
pour intervenir à l'extérieur du
territoire national
l'armée française dispose de deux
grandes unités la 11ème division
parachutiste et la 9e division
d'infanterie de marine
la 11ème division parachutiste est
installé dans le sud ouest de la france
elle comprend six régiments
parachutistes dont le 2e rep qui est
allé à kolwezi et les 3e et 8e rpima qui
sont allés au liban pour l'onu trois
régiments composé entièrement d'engagés
volontaires la 9e division d'infanterie
de marine est implantée elle dans
l'ouest de la france allait composé de
sept régiments dont deux sont
actuellement servi totalement par des
professionnels interventions de ses
hommes sur le terrain se fait
généralement dans des hôtels
écourt quelques jours seulement pour
mettre sur pied et acheminer le
détachement de la force intérimaire de
l'onu au liban quelques heures seulement
pour l'opération de kolwezi
ces deux unités d'intervention ont donc
en permanence une compagnie en alerte
elle porte le nom de compagnie guépard
ses 138 tonnes doit pouvoir monter dans
les transall quelques minutes seulement
après l'ordre donné par le gouvernement
c'est cette rapidité qui fait leur
valeur et leur intérêt à la fois pour la
france mais aussi pour les pays liés aux
nôtres par des accords de défense
m
hier soir au cours de l'émission
d'antenne d'europe numéro un que
présenter jean pierre elkabbach et en
europe
monsieur georges marchais attaquer une
nouvelle fois le parti socialiste qui
l'a accusé de virer à droite et entre
autres de s'aligner sur la politique de
monsieur helmut schmidt chancelier
d'allemagne fédérale monsieur laurent
fabius a jugé inacceptables les propos
du secrétaire général du parti
communiste français et le parti
socialiste a décidé de l'y réplique est
immédiate
tout se passe comme en 1978
c'est à dire que georges marchais
concentre ses attaques contre le parti
socialiste contre les militants
socialistes et contre le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste et il est
dans cette affaire le meilleur défenseur
de la droite
alors il ajoute ici et là une anecdote
qu'il a soigneusement fabriqué qui est
inventé de toute pièce et il s'agit là
de procédure qui nous rappelle un autre
temps que nous espérions dépassé et qui
sont gênés fait inadmissible j'ajouterai
un mot une interrogation à georges
marchais grave est ce qu il croit que
cette en instruisant des procès de
moscou contre les socialistes qu'il
défend la cause des travailleurs
avez vous l'intention de répondre chaque
fois et ne croyez vous pas que de ce
fait le ton montera encore nous avons
pris comme attitude de ne pas répondre à
la polémique mais quand elle passe les
bornes et c'est le cas cette fois ci il
faut mettre le holà nous continuons à
feuilleter notre lexique européens
aujourd'hui georges bortoli ouvre ce
lexique à la page supranationalité mais
le terme est-il encore valables et ne
vaut-il pas mieux parler maintenant de
l'europe des nations
les pères de l'europe comme le belge ce
pack
le français jean monnet l'allemand
adenauer était plutôt de tendance
supranationale robert schuman pensait
dans ces années 50 peut pour éviter de
nouvelles guerres fratricides les
nations européennes devaient abandonner
un peu de leurs privilèges un peu de
leur souveraineté pour se fondre dans
l'ensemble europe dans la super nation
europe
mais quand de gaulle 120 offrir aux
allemands la règle
filiation franco allemandes ont vite que
la démarche était autre au lieu d'une
europe intégrée de gaulle préconisait
une europe des états des nations unies
europe où chaque pays tout en
s'associant aux autres garderait toutes
ses prérogatives c'est cette tendance là
qui a prévalu aujourd'hui en france tout
le monde ou presque se réclame de
l'europe des nations ce qui règle en
somme une vieille querelle de lexique la
confédération où les états membres
gardent leur souveraineté
la confédération l'emportent sur la
fédération plus intégrés ou les états
membres se soumette un ensemble fédéral
et tout indique que le lexique européen
restera ouvert à cette page confédéral
demain soir les socialistes européens
invite les parisiens à concerts et aux
feux d'artifice bref à une fête pour
célébrer le printemps socialiste dès
demain après-midi des rencontres et une
conférence de presse donneront le temps
politique de cette manifestation la plus
parlée deiber socialistes seront là la
soirée sera précédée d'un message de
willy brandt et de françois mitterrand
elle se terminera par l'audition de la
symphonie fantastique de berlioz exécuté
par le london symphony orchestra
dès aujourd'hui la fête se préparer en
pop majeur un podium géant pour la
musique des pétards et des fusées pour
le ciel et pour tous quatre heures le
spectacle sociale les amateurs de
planche à roulettes frôleront james
callaghan mario soares jobs des naïve il
faut leur ont aussi des jambes connu
pour des raisons autres que politiques
c'est en effet madame mercouri députés
grecs qui prononcera le discours
d'ouverture de cette célébration du
printemps social sentimentale
et en étant une femme qui adore paris et
qui a la culture française et qui depuis
toute ma vie j'ai adoré la france et que
la france ne l'a rendu si bien je
voudrais vie paris je t'aime pas plutôt
paresseux prendre mais vous lui dites au
milieu d'autres socialistes européens
c'est quand même un paris je t'aime qui
est un petit peu politisés mais voyez
vous moi en étant socialiste je crois
que c'est la meilleure traçant des
régions
une chorale luxembourgeoise trois lasers
50 figurants costumés
tout absolument tout sera prêt demain
soir pourvu qu'il ne pleuve pas
conférence de presse de jacques
chaban-delmas et d'après midi à biarritz
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
déclaré que son enlèvement projetée par
des autonomistes basques de l'êta cet
enlèvement donc éventuels se révéler
difficile il utile difficile a dit mme
soutenant des menaces parce que les
mesures de sécurité adoptées par le
gouvernement français sont efficaces
inutile parce que dans une lettre au
président de la république je lui ai
demandé une masse qu'en cas d'enlèvement
il ne soit tenu aucun compte des
exigences des reds à nice un inspecteur
de police de la brigade de recherche et
d'intervention a été tué dans des
circonstances dramatiques et un autre
blessé par les malfaiteurs qu'ils
poursuivaient dans l'arrière pays niçois
les policiers avaient rattrapé les
quatre malfaiteurs en voiture ceux ci on
va leur tirer l'un des policiers
s'engageait à pied sur un pont atteint
d'une balle de revolver il a fait une
chute de 30 mètres dans la rivière
vésubie et son corps n'avait pas été
retrouvé encore en fin de matinée les
noms des policiers et ceux des
malfaiteurs n'ont pas aidé comme unique
proche orient selon un porte parole
israélien des appareils de l'aviation
israéliennes ont effectué un raid ce
matin contre les concentrations des
fedayins dans le sud liban tous les
appareils sont rentrés indemnes repas
dimanche rencontre entre le président
sadate et monsieur begin premier
ministre israélien à beersheba en israël
pour commencer les négociations sur
l'autonomie de cisjordanie et du mois en
cisjordanie et à gaza quand la ville
d'al arish capitale du sinaï elle sera
rendue demain vendredi par israël à
l'egypte en vertu du récent traité de
paix entre les deux pays
mais les colons israéliens et les ultra
religieux s'oppose pas la restitution du
divers incidents
en 48 heures ce kibboutz de neode sinaï
à quelques kilomètres d'el arish et
devenue le symbole de la colère des
colons du sinaï ce qu'ils refusent
d'évacuer les points de peuplement les
ultrareligieux les militants du bloc de
la fois s'oppose à la restitution du
sinaï à l'egypte étaient venus leur
prêter main forte et bombardait l'armée
israélienne avec des tomates pourries et
des tonnes il a fallu deux heures de
bataille rangée avec l'armée pour qu'ils
acceptent de quitter les lieux
à part quelques blessés tout s'est bien
terminé finalement par une brève
cérémonie d'adieu qui a permis de
réconcilier soldats et manifestants
mais les premiers pas de la paix sont
hésitants l'egypte refuse à présent
d'ouvrir tout de suite la nouvelle
frontière
sadate freine le processus de paix avec
israël et attend que des progrès soient
faits dans les négociations sur
l'autonomie de la cisjordanie
cela n'empêche pas ses ministres de
garder leur optimisme au moment où nous
avons commencé ces mêmes négociations il
ya 16 mois en novembre et 277 l'écart
entre les positions égyptienne et des
positions israéliennes était aussi grand
que l'écart qui existe aujourd'hui et
les difficultés que nous avons
aujourd'hui pour les négociations
concernant l'autonomie dans la
cisjordanie et de gaza malgré soucis
malgré les obstacles nous sommes arrivés
à surmonter ses difficultés et nous
avons conclu en mars d'avenir washington
de traiter donc si je perds ce parallèle
je pouvais dire que je suis optimiste
au début de ces nouvelles négociations
pour mettre fin par quelle astuce
juridique puis ou substituer aux
palestiniens ne se substitue pas au
prestige au compteur d'abord nous sommes
en contact choristes en second lieu ce
que nous essayons de faire c'est
d'obtenir un cac
une fois que ce cadre établi et que les
élections il y aura une autorité
palestinienne qui elle va vraiment
négocier nous sommes à une étape
intermédiaire qui consiste à pouvoir
aider d'avoir un interlocuteur valable
pour israël bien cet interlocuteur
d'arabes seraient l'autorité
palestinienne qui seul hic la gaza et en
cisjordanie en iran live est terminé a
condamné tous les groupements dans le
programme dit il mais pas celui de la
république islamique en les qualifiant
d' ennemis de la nation et en demandant
au peuple iranien d'agir en conséquence
cinq nouveaux militaires ont été passés
par les armes mais dans le même temps
des mesures d'aidé prises qui pourrait
signifier une libéralisation dans la
répression contre les partisans du
régime du shah ainsi 70 anciens
parlementaires ont été libérés et 700
des plus politiques ont été libérés
également aux états unis les chances de
monsieur edward kennedy le jeune frère
du président assassiné en 1963 et chance
d'être le candidat du parti démocrate
dans la course à la maison blanche
augmente
bien que monsieur kennedy prétendent
qu'il ne se présentera jamais contre
monsieur carter par ailleurs monsieur
merkel ans ancien directeur de la
gestion et du budget des états unis a
été inculpé pour indélicatesse bancaire
à l'époque où monsieur carter était
gouverneur de l'état de gerges de
washington jacques sylla
à quelque chose malheur est bon monsieur
trudeau premier ministre du canada ayant
été battu aux élections son épouse la
belle remontée margaret trudeau a
annoncé qu'elle allait revenir au
domicile conjugal pour soutenir le moral
de son mari vous savez qu'ils sont
séparés depuis deux ans margaret a dit
maintenant qu'il n'est plus chef de
gouvernement
mais les leaders de l'opposition il va
montrer ses adversaires politiques que
c'est un chef de l'opposition formidable
il ne luttera pas seulement pour la
défense de libertés individuelles
il combattra aussi l'ennui combattre
l'ennui est une des spécialités de
margaret trudeau elle nous en donnent la
main sur l'écran une nouvelle preuve
elle a d'ailleurs fait ces déclarations
à new york au club 54 et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que c'était dans une
ans qui n'engendrait pas là mais l'anc
sport d'abord l'arrivée du tiercé qui se
courait à longchamp agnel à qui tout est
neuf danseurs c'est à dire 9 4 6 je n'ai
pas encore je crois les rapports ce soir
à strasbourg départ de la grande épreuve
de marche
le classique strasbourg paris organisé
par le parisien libéré l'équipe à
bruxelles comment ces championnats
d'europe de judo une chance de belles
médailles pour la france avec rouge est
dans la catégorie des lourds
enfin et surtout dirais-je en cyclisme
bernard hinault trouve la forme à point
nommé et prend le maillot jaune du
dauphiné libéré
comme prévu le mont ventoux a été un
juge impitoyable dans cette 3e étape du
dauphiné libéré qui conduisait les
coureurs de tournon avignon dès les
premiers lacets le peloton devait
éclater et une première échappée de cet
homme réduite à néant
alors que le soleil jouer à cache cache
avec les nuages seuls les hommes en
forme pouvait suivre le train d'enfer
imposé par sven nilsson le coéquipier de
zoo thoneick puis peur d'abord
baronchelli ensuite devait lâcher prise
si bien qu'à moins de 10 kilomètres du
sommet il restait quatre en tête
hinault je tenais là nilsson et lucia
morny il était important pour ces
coureurs de passer en tête au sommet du
mont ventoux puisque une bonification de
20 secondes et est offerte au premier ce
qui voulait dire le maillot jaune
le leader de ce dauphiné l'allemand tu
as l'air étant déjà à plus de 4 minutes
on savait le landaise de melk en forme
puisque récent vainqueur du tour
d'espagne
mais bernard hinault devait utiliser la
manière forte imposant souris moyens
demain et bien sûr l'ensemble du pays un
temps variable avec comme aujourd'hui
des du soleil des éclaircies mais
également des passages magie avec des
averses parfois orageuses plus abondante
de la manche à la belgique
les nuages viendront sur les régions
pyrénéennes et une partie de l'aquitaine
avec des précipitations montagne sur les
régions méditerranéennes
après quelques orages sur la corse et le
sud-est du soleil samedi ça va un peu
s'aggraver avec la traversée du sud
ouest vers le nord d'une bande de pluie
qui amènera à son passage des plus un
peu plus forte encore pas trop trop
grave
avant et après toujours le temps
variable je vous conseille donc de
prendre un parapluie avec vous en
promenade et de l'ouvrir si l'averse
arrive ce soir la dernière édition vous
sera présentée par bernard pradines
nous retrouverons patrick lecocq
quarantaine de midi de maroua et nous
terminerons cette édition par le gala
européen de la danse qui a lieu ce soir
au théâtre des champs-elysées la
manifestation est due à l'initiative de
jean alio et à celle du mouvement pour
l'europe qui veulent ainsi sensibiliser
l'opinion pour question culturelle car
ils sont d'avis que les hommes
politiques n'y attache pas suffisamment
d'importance participer à ce gala
de nombreuses vedettes de la scala de
milan de l'opéra de londres et des
ballets de hambourg de copenhague et des
pays bas voici un extrait du spectacle
filmé pendant les répétitions
je vous laisse regarder bonsoir merci
et si vous le voulez bien admet m
non
et